So very quickly here,
I'm going to show you
one of the voice agent
I built.
This one specifically is for
MeetingScheduled.
And it could either be
when a user
fills up a form on
your website and then the
voice agent immediately calls
him.
Or when it's an after
-hour service or we create
some sort of an automation
that the user commits an
action and then receives a
call.
So if I go here,
we can just test it.
Thanks for calling
MeetingScheduled.
How can I help you
today?
Yeah, I was just looking
to understand a bit about
your service here.
Sure, I'm happy to help.
MeetingScheduled builds digital
phone receptionists for
businesses, so your calls can
be answered automatically,
even after hours or when
your team is busy.
What kind of business do
you run?
Good.
I have an outbound agency.
Thanks for sharing.
When your customers call in,
what do they usually need
help with?
Well, usually they look to
increase sales and have more
qualified appointments.
That makes sense for an
outbound agency.
Do you find that you
miss calls during busy times,
or do you already have
someone answering every inbound
call?
Yeah, I do.
So this agent,
we can modify her and
we can change her voice.
It would be different language.
I have an agent that
speaks German and
different dialects as well in
German.
If you want to try,
you can just call this
number and you will be
able to try it out
and speak to her.